kentucky's attorney general could
announce as soon as today whether a
grand jury
called for criminal charges in the
briana taylor case
the louisville police officers who
killed the emergency medical worker in
her home during a botched
drug raid have been under investigation
for several months this morning
buildings in downtown louisville are
boarded up
in case of protests and the city has
already declared a state of emergency
our national correspondent jerica duncan
is there jerica good morning to you
what's the attorney general saying
good morning gail he's not saying much
but sources tell cbs news that an
announcement is eminent likely happening
this week no matter what the decision
though
businesses and restaurants as you can
see in this popular downtown area
are boarded up and the mayor and police
chief here
say they're ready we are merely taking
steps we feel are necessary
to protect the public interim louisville
police chief robert schroeder says he's
implementing safety measures
ahead of an announcement from kentucky
attorney general daniel cameron
you're saying that the city is not on
lockdown but it feels like
it is i could understand some members of
the public how people would feel that
way but that is certainly not our
intention
cameron's office is expected to announce
whether sergeant jonathan mattingly
miles cosgrove and former detective
brett hankinson will face charges
in the shooting death of brianna taylor
on tuesday cbs news obtained a copy of
an email
mattingly sent to his colleagues
expressing his support for them ahead of
the decision
it reads in part regardless of the
outcome i know we did the legal
moral and ethical thing that night it's
sad how the good guys are demonized
and the criminals are canonized i asked
the police chief about mattingly's
message
that's a situation that's currently
developing it's simply too premature at
this time to talk about it
cbs news also obtained the more than
1200 crime scene photos from the march
13
shooting that left taylor dead police
used a no knock warrant to raid her
apartment looking for drugs and money
taylor's boyfriend kenneth walker says
he assumed the police were intruders
and fired one shot police fired back
hitting taylor
five times bullets were found all over
the apartment and in neighboring units
police never found what they were
looking for
as we await the news of possible state
charges chief schroeder says the safety
measures will stay in place
i hope we hope that all of this
is simply not needed that it will be a
peaceful situation
and this week the louisville metro
police department announced that they're
investigating three
additional officers in taylor's case
saying they may have potentially broken
department policies gail
i'll take this one drika thank you very
much